Адріан був його капітаном армії США
раніше, тому ти тут волонтер,
або
я пішов на службу в українську
армію, тому я з військовими, а
раніше ти був тим, ким ти був
наставником для українців,
коли  Війна почалася для мене та двох інших
ветеранів армії США, фактично один
ветеран армії та ветеран морської піхоти приїхали до Левіва
на початку березня,
щоб допомогти навчити ну як громадянські
сили оборони,
і ви пам’ятаєте початок
війни, ніхто насправді не знав, що
відбувалося, або що буде далі,
здавалося можливим, що Білорусь
увійде або росіяни
атакуватимуть яловичину безпосередньо, тож ми прийшли туди,
я думаю, можливо, 2 березня, і ми
навчали цих
волонтерів цих цивільних базовій
тактиці невеликих підрозділів і малих
керівництво підрозділу, і вони показали себе надзвичайно добре.
Я ніколи не бачив, щоб хтось тренувався так
швидко й ефективно,
і
коли ми пішли, було очевидно,
що українські військові справляються з
Росією дуже ефективно, так що нам не
потрібні були такі речі  але це те, що
ми
все одно почали
протягом дев’яти років, так, з 2014 року.
Отже, я вперше,
коли я вперше приїхав в Україну, я приїхав у
2015 році, і я приїхав як журналіст, щоб висвітлити
тренінг США для навчання
волонтерів у Яварєєві,
і я думаю,  Можливо, я був одним із
перших журналістів, які написали, щоб сказати, але я
думав, виходячи з того, що я там побачив, що
українці можуть перемогти Росію, тому я
написав це, і я не думаю, що мене
більше вітають у Росії, як наслідок.  Ви все ще
бачите, можливо, зміни в
українській армії з 2015 року,
і тепер
я думаю, що
неможливо пропустити вплив
досвіду 2014 і 2015 років на
армію. У
вас є люди, які пам’ятають, які знають
багато про радянську  У
Хана були ці молодші солдати, молодші
офіцери, які навчилися власному стилю
тактики та доктрини частково від НАТО,
частково завдяки досвіду на Донбасі
на сході,
і те, що ви зараз бачите в українській
армії, є захоплюючим, цього немає більше
ніде у світі, це  Неповторна
для України, дякую вам так багато, іноземне
[Музика]